es el mejor mundial de todos los tiempos
así definió el presidente de la FIFA ya
ni infantil nuestra copa mundo descartar
2022 en su última rueda de prensa dos
días de esa gran final entre Argentina y
Francia infantino que manifestó que ha
habido un gran éxito en este certamen el
presidente del máximo ente regidor del
balompique abordó también las cuestiones
sobre Por qué se prohibió llevar
brazaletes con la bandera del orgullo en
los campos dijo infantino que hayan
reglas que respetar además también
abordó preguntas sobre las denuncias de
obreros muertos en la construcción de
los estadios de esta copa mundo
infantino que se adhiera la versión
oficial de la organización tres obreros
fallecidos de manera directa por esas
obras al margen de estos temas
importantes anuncios por parte de
infantino de cara al calendario del
balompié Internacional por un lado
infantino que consiguió una importante
Victoria después de la reunión del
Consejo de la FIFA habrá un nuevo
Mundial de Clubes una de las grandes
apuestas que tenía infantino desde que
llegó a la presidencia de la FIFA será
un Mundial de Clubes con 32 equipos que
se va a realizar por primera vez en 202